[Music]
welcome home honey
do you read now what is this it's
classified
oh I'm sorry
you weren't invited
they call it bad behavior
hey why are you here I got this
situation when I need your help I need
bad friends
cause I'm the new guy is that sniper
don't worry about it I got a
prescription oh guys remember this face
oh shoot it by accident
terrorists have taken possession of
nuclear missiles on a cargo ship off the
coast
if these babies go off
it'll be world war three
to choose this life over friends
over family
It's Time to Get Loud
next slide baby
[Music]
of imitation distance constitutes the
reservation
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
is that the biggest one you've got oh
it's way bigger than that
all right
[Music]